a rough day for President Trump as his
longtime personal lawyer goes to the
clink for three years what does this
mean for the Trump presidency then Ann
Coulter gets in trouble for telling the
truth as she usually does Google helps
Democrats win elections and the
government might shut down I sure hope
so
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
we've also got to get to the new
politically correct version of baby it's
cold outside we'll get to that at the
end it is my favorite thing going around
the internet but first let's make a
little bit of money honey let's talk
about pro talis with over 1 million
happy pain-free customers and a 97%
success rate Pro talus insoles have
changed the footwear industry and
created a new level of expectation never
seen before for comfortable all day
shoes Pro talus has helped over a
million people experience relief it's a
unique technology it's proven incredibly
effective there's an unconditional
90-day love them or your money back
guarantee you will not want your money
back
they are absolutely great I didn't
realize this myself but a lot of knee
issues hip issues back issues even upper
body muscle tightness can stem from
improper alignment and that all begins
at the foot in fact this is true for 80%
of people it might have been true for me
I love these insoles their most Footwear
even very expensive quality shoes offer
at most minimal support where the foot
needs at most
these are different what makes pro talus
unique and different from anything else
as they are engineered with the focus on
biomechanics of your body so it is
engineered to support your body based on
very basic body mechanics over a hundred
thousand five-star reviews positive
reviews this holiday season only my
listeners can save 20 bucks per pair on
any pro Telus in Seoul at portalis comm
when you enter podcast 20 at check out
this one will lowest prices that your
exclusively for our loyal listeners
shipping is free if you buy two or more
pairs they will upgrade you to free
expedited shipping 90 day money-back
guarantee but you won't want it nothing
to lose except for pain pro talus comm
promo code podcast 20 to save 20 bucks
per pair on any pro talus insole where I
want to begin today I don't want to
begin with Michael Cohen going to the
clink for three years I don't want to
begin with an Coulter being right even I
don't even want to begin with the new
politically correct version of maybe
it's cold outside
I want to begin with a ridiculous canard
that we keep hearing in the mainstream
media which is that Donald Trump is the
reason why our political discourse is
rude Donald Trump is destroying our
discourse he's destroying the norm
of our discourse other politicians would
never speak the way Trump does other
politicians would never pick the fights
that Trump does other media figures
would never be s this started way before
Donald Trump and even the fights that
we're seeing now are being picked by the
left and Trump is responding and then
when Trump responds he gets yelled at
and and the country's angry with him for
starting the fight he didn't start it
he's just responding case in point is
Nancy Pelosi you saw that that wonderful
oval office meeting yesterday where it
was Chuck and Nancy and then President
Trump and Mike Pence just shaking his
head in pure misery thinking how did I
get here what did I do wrong in my life
that I'm sitting in this office right
now
and so they had their little fight so
Nancy Pelosi comes out of that meeting
and this is what CNN reports she said
according to an aide in the room Pelosi
told colleagues behind closed doors the
quote it's like a manhood thing for him
as if manhood could ever be associated
with him this wall thing discourse in
this country is it such a wonderful
level isn't it I share her sorrow that
discourse has fallen to that level but
it's Nancy Pelosi who did it it's Nancy
Pelosi who's saying that Donald Trump
only wants to build the wall because
he's insecure about his manhood not
because there were 3,000 illegal aliens
poring over our border every day not
because we have record high levels of
illegal immigration into this country
not because illegal aliens access our
welfare system at a much higher rate
than native-born Americans and we have a
massive welfare system right now and we
have over 20 trillion dollars in debt we
have a high debt to GDP ratio not
because in certain areas illegal aliens
commit a disproportionate share of
violent crime not any of that it's
because of his manhood because Trump
isn't a man you see ha ha ha
and and it's not just her it's not just
her who did it you'll remember during
the 2016 presidential primaries Donald
Trump brought up
he made a penis joke at a presidential
debate except he didn't he's not the guy
to bring it up the first guy to make a
penis joke at a presidential debate was
Marco Rubio who was making it about
Trump do you remember he said Donald
Trump has small hands and you know what
they say about small hands and then
Donald Trump responded to that and he
said I'm
just fine thank you my body is looking
just fine but it was Rubio who brought
it up it was not Donald Trump who
started the bickering in the Oval Office
yesterday we played the clip Trump was
being very nice he was playing
relatively friendly in that oval office
meeting it was Nancy Pelosi who said we
don't want a government shutdown we
don't want a Trump shutdown and he said
what was that come again the Trump shut
down and then she went after him she's
the one who broke that cordial meeting
up she's the one who tried to get her
little line in and who made the comment
afterward Nancy Pelosi she's who did and
so I just don't want to hear it anymore
it's true that Donald Trump is better at
doing insults than the left is it's true
that he's funnier at it and he gets more
play and obviously he's the president so
he just has more of a bully pulpit but
he's not the one who's starting this
this has been true throughout Trump's
career he gets he gets critiqued for
being mean or being brash or whatever
but he is always responding even it was
with his big major fight against Rosie
O'Donnell Rosie O'Donnell went on
television and said Donald Trump is
bankrupt he goes bankrupt all the time
and after she said that Donald Trump
unleashed the Furies of Hell on her for
months at a time
and called her fat and ugly and stupid
and all of these awful things but it was
her who started it that's the same thing
that's going on here there's another
irony too by the way which is that Nate
Silver he's the pollster guy whose
entire career is based on predicting
that Barack Obama would win elections
and he tweeted out yesterday and said
the the only reason that Republicans
don't like Alexandria Ocasio cortez is
her gender and her race which I guess
makes us anti-semites because now she's
a Jew she's a trans Jew I don't know I
think she's a bad as Jewish as Elizabeth
Warren is Cherokee but he's saying the
only reason that Republicans don't like
her is because of bigotry I thought it
was Alexandria's blithe ignorance but
apparently it's some sort of bigotry and
he also said what they don't understand
is that Alexandria Ocasio Cortez talks
like a New Yorker she doesn't talk like
DC people or middle America people okay
now do that for Trump now do the same
exact thing for Trump because Donald
Trump actually does talk like a New
Yorker and
unlike Alexandria Ocasio Cortez who
pretends to be Jenny from the block even
though she grew up in an affluent
Westchester suburb one town over from
where I grew up actually she grew up in
the nicer town than where I grew up
Donald Trump actually was raised in
Queens if he actually does talk like a
guy from Queens
but of course Nate Silver wouldn't do
that the left won't do this it is a
hideous double standard and just the
other last point I want to make about
Nancy Pelosi's comment is I'm very
confused now his manhood a good thing or
a bad thing because she's insulting
Trump and saying manhood could never be
associated with Donald Trump okay but I
thought manhood was toxic his manhood
good or bad is it a virtue or is it
toxic which one isn't is Trump manly or
he's on he's too manly he's a masculine
machismo chauvinist or he's unmanly
which one is it I'm not not quite sure
I'm not sure they're quite sure either
it isn't just bias though by the way
among these politicians it is it has
reached a fever pitch in the mainstream
media when their ago after the not only
president Trump but after members of his
administration here was MSNBC's mika
brzezinski joe scarborough's most recent
future wife talking about the u.s.
relationship with saudi arabia and
specifically how Mike Pompeo is managing
this very delicate relationship that is
what would you expect her to say she'd
say well he's got to balance this
because they're the new crown prince of
Saudi Arabia is a reformer and he's
being kinder toward the west and Kandra
toward Israel and he's balancing out the
trouble of in the grave nuclear threat
of Iran in the Middle East no no no she
didn't say any of that she called him a
but boy here's mica so Joe I just I have
to ask because I don't think there I
can't think of anyone here who could put
it more clearly than you know I
understand that Donald Trump doesn't
care
Heilmann makes a good point he doesn't
care but why doesn't Mike Pompeo care
now are the pathetic deflections that we
just heard when he appeared on Fox and
Friends is that a patriot speaking or a
wannabe dictators butt boy dead serious
I'm asking are these the words of a
patriot used to baste himself he once
again is undercut the conclusions of our
Intel community so you if you were just
listening you might have assumed that
was an SNL skit of the morning Joe show
it's not that was the real thing she
really said it and if you heard that
little skip in the audio that wasn't on
our end it's because MSNBC tried to
catch that word but it student they
missed it it was too late she goes he
looks like a but boy beep like guys
maybe a little faster maybe hire a
producer who's got a faster trigger
finger but look look what was included
in that she questioned his patriotism
whenever a conservative questions of
Democrats patriotism what are we go how
awful Democrats are protesting the
American flag remember Michelle Obama
said she was never proud of her country
Barack Obama said he doesn't believe in
American exceptionalism
he said it's no different than any other
country's exceptionalism because he
doesn't even understand what that term
means and so when we questioned their
patriotism
that's how dare you how dare you but
then when you have the Secretary of
State Mike Pompeo who is just trying to
manage a very delicate situation and
then up not blow up the whole Middle
East she says he's not patriotic and
he's a but boy which raises another
question we were asked the question
about Nancy Pelosi and Donald Trump's
manhood what is it is it good to be gay
or is it bad to be gay is it ridiculous
to be gay is it worthy of derision to be
gay because when you use a term like but
boy you're referring to gay sex that's
what it that's what she's referring to
so on the one hand we're told that we
should we're living in a culture that
affirms homosexuality it's okay to be
gay it's great to be gay paint the White
House and rainbow colors on the other
hand though it's the left who is using
gay slurs to make fun of their opponents
and okay that's fine I'm I'm all for
telling jokes about every group of
people that's just fine but which one is
it which is it they can't give an answer
to that and it goes so much further it
goes to CNN
it goes it goes to the heights of
left-wing commentary and left-wing news
but first before we can before we can
get to Don Lemon and Anderson Cooper we
have to make a little money and thank
our advertiser at Brownells Brownells is
a big proponent and supporter of the
Second Amendment they have been for 80
years what you should know about
Brownells is their online and buying
guns ammo accessories online is
convenient it's totally legal a lot of
new people are coming into the fold of
firearm ownership young people women
urbanites they're taking an interest in
firearms and self-protection and I'll
tell you one thing I noticed in
California whenever I have the an
impulse to get a new gun or to get some
new accessory it's whenever they make it
illegal whenever they say in two months
it's going to be illegal then all of us
firearm enthusiasts rush out we go buy
it because you want to get grandfathered
in and a great way to do this is
Brownells it's the world's leading
supplier of firearms ammunition firearm
accessories reloading components and
more they offer an industry exclusive
guaranteed forever warranty on all parts
and accessories they offer nearly a
hundred twenty thousand items from new
guns and ammo to nearly any gun part
managable they have more than 5,500
partner FFL around the country to make
your online gun purchase go smoothly
it's family owned veteran owned has been
doing business in the country's
heartland for 80 years don't forget
about the gun guy or gal on your
Christmas list namely me send me great
Brownells gift cards for christmas
they make great stocking stuffers go to
Brownells comm put some freedom in your
loved ones Christmas give the gift of
freedom it is greif oh I can't wait if
when I wake up on Christmas I go to my
stocking and I see a Brownells gift card
have I made this clear that I want you
to send me Brownells gift cards all
right I think I've driven the point home
it's not just mika brzezinski
this goes all the way to CNN the the
bias some people lament the exposure of
media bias they say I wish we had this
objective media like we like they
imagined that we used to have we never
had it they just hit it before now
they're not hiding it and here is Don
Lemon on CNN thanking God for Nancy
Pelosi I say that today because as I was
saying you know taking the theraflu
nighttime this morning as I was laying
in bed then this afternoon and I saw
this on television and just objectively
speaking I say oh my gosh
Nancy Pelosi is a boss I mean she
handles herself amazingly a lot of
people don't like Nancy Pelosi
I'm sure Democrats are going all across
the country and I thank God for Nancy
Pelosi he's sure because he's a Democrat
who said that last night because she is
amazing and she's a boss just
objectively speaking just and we're not
talking subjectively we're just saying
objectively I like that he's coming out
in saying this I actually got kind of a
kick out of Don Lemon and Chris Cuomo
because they're both total partisan
Democrats and you know Don Lemon is way
out there I believe he was the guy at
CNN speculating that the Malaysia
airline that went missing was abducted
by aliens that's sort of the caliber of
political analysis at CNN and he goes
out there he says yeah I love Nancy
Pelosi she's amazing she's a boss
Democrats are thanking God for Nancy
Pelosi I go on Fox and Friends about
once a week once or twice a week and Fox
and Friends gets dragged through the mud
all of Fox News gets dragged through the
mud because they say oh it's Trump's
Pravda
they're just cheerleaders for Donald
Trump they have a relationship with
Donald Trump first of all that isn't
true Shepard Smith one of their main
news guys is a liberal Democrat Chris
Wallace who's there on Sundays on Fox is
a is a Democrat I believe they have a
number of Democrat commentators who are
peppered throughout their shows they
have a wide variety of political thought
in the commentary they lean right
obviously but in the news they don't
what what's CNN's excuse that was
supposed to be a news program that we
were watching and they are actually
cheering on Nancy Pelosi thanking God
for Nancy Pelosi calling her objectively
a boss and amazing I don't begrudge them
but they're pretending to be something
that they're not that if you want to
talk about Fox and Friends being Donald
Trump's breakfast companion oh okay
that's fine
but they bring different perspectives on
that show what is CNN's excuse I never
hear the left lamenting how CNN is
nothing but a communication shop for
Democrats and it's not that this is a
new thing again it's not that Donald
Trump started all of this this has been
going on for years
if you don't remember back back in those
days before Donald Trump when the news
was objective and our political
discourse was so elevated here's CNN's
Anderson Cooper putting that myth to
rest this happened so minority party
after it's lost a couple of bad
elections but they're searching for
their voice it's hard to talk in your
tea bagging David well thanks very much
hard to talk when your tea bagging so
that's Anderson Cooper who is gay
talking about tea bagging which if you
don't know what it is don't google it
you don't need to google it but it
refers to gay sex and this is this was
years ago this was long before Donald
Trump this was during the height of the
tea party you've got Mika Brzezinski
talking about but boys and so it's it's
also a selective outrage Kevin Hart
doesn't get to host the Oscars because
he told a gay joke during a stand-up set
ten years ago but ostensibly objective
news presenters make gay comments
regularly on seeing it nobody says a
thing imagine if a conservative said but
boy on fox news we're on The Daily wire
or on any other conservative outlet
imagine what would happen imagine
certainly they'd be kicked off Twitter
they'd probably be kicked off YouTube
they'd be kicked off of all of these
platforms but there is a double standard
now there's a double standard and we
only blame conservatives we pretend that
conservatives started we pretend that
Donald Trump starts the fights he
doesn't he answers the fights he doesn't
start them we pretend that right-wing
political commentators start the fights
they don't this has been going on for
years and years and we are simply
answering back and we should make no
apologies for it if if the left wants to
fix political discourse be my guest
you started it you're leading you can
fix it but we're not gonna unilaterally
disarm no chance buster and one of the
people who best exemplifies this in the
media is my my friend my imagined
romantic you know ex-girlfriend if you
listen to the show and Ann Coulter was
on my program and Coulter was on Fox
News she is trending on Twitter she was
getting dragged through the mud because
of accurately describing leftist
intersectional ideology she puts it
succinctly and now they're accusing her
of every this ISM and
ISM and that ISM and everything else I
think we're gonna be seeing a lot of
these disputes in in the Democratic
Party base because they all hate one
another I mean you have the Muslims and
the Jews and the various exotic sexual
groups and the the black church ladies
with with you know the college queers
the only thing that keeps this the
Democratic base together is for them to
keep focusing on no white men are the
one keep one's keeping you down you must
hate white men it's the one thing they
all have in common
show me the lie show me the lie what
what the left is trying to do is as they
always do they're trying to twist what
she said and make it fit their agenda so
they're saying Ann Coulter just said
that the Democrats are full of Jews and
Muslims and queers but that isn't what
she said she is making the point that
the Democrat coalition because of
intersectional ideology and the politics
of identity is now made up of groups of
people who actually disagree with one
another and have long-standing animosity
stored at one another and the only thing
that is unifying them is their disdain
for white men particularly straight
white men particularly straight white
men who think that they are men because
in this ideology at the apex of the
oppression hierarchy sits the straight
white man who thinks that he is a man
and therefore if there are other groups
who have long-standing ideological and
historical animosities for one another
they can all work together to fight the
bad guy who is the straight white guy
who is the straight white guy who knows
that he's a guy and this is absolutely
right so she points out that you have
Jews and Muslims within the coalition
Jews and Muslims in the history of
international politics tend to have some
harsh disagreements with one another but
they sit together you have the black
church ladies and you have the college
queers
now some people are dividing her use of
the term queer queer is now the term
this is at the LGBT cue there's a queue
for queer there a couple queues actually
in the acronym but queer is a term that
has been embraced by people of
she says exotic sexualities and so she's
using the term that they themselves are
using and it is true it doesn't make any
sense that the black church lady is you
know somebody who embraces at least a
great deal of traditional Christian
moral teaching would ally with people
who want to tear down a traditional
Christian moral teaching and who
disagree with traditional Christian
moral teaching but they ally together
because there they are said a lie that
they are victims that they are oppressed
by this awful evil fantastical person
called the straight white guy who thinks
that he's a guy this is true across the
board and it's it's why intersectional
politics identity politics has been so
successful is this is I mean the left
has always done this to some degree they
create class conflict or racial conflict
or they try to create gender conflict
they try to start a gender war but that
never works there will never be a gender
war because in the gender war everybody
is sleeping with the enemy or almost
everybody is sleeping with the enemy so
that's not going to last but everyone
else they so this division and the best
way that they can do it is to isolate a
very specific person the straight white
guy who thinks he's a guy and say that
he's harming everybody no evidence of
that of course and everyone he has to
band up against him this is why during
Occupy Wall Street they had their
language of the 99% versus the 1%
it's very politically useful to get an
entire lynch mob to mob up on a very
small minority I'm sure if they had
thought of it they would have made it
the 99.9 percent against the point one
percent that point one percent doesn't
stand a chance when you just look at the
plain numbers and so this is the point
that Ann Coulter is making she's
observing it and and I hope that certain
left-wing Democrats or people who have
been taken in by intersectionality might
listen to what she's saying because what
she's pointing out is they're they're
being tricked they're being used they're
being they're having their rage ginned
up by people who don't want to address
the actual issues that these groups care
about what they want to do is while them
up so much that they stop thinking and
they blindly follow the left-wing and
the Democratic Party because they are
being fed a lie
that they have an enemy in the oppressor
and the patriarchy and the straight
white guy who thinks that he's a guy
nobody's problems comes from the
straight white guy who thinks that he's
a guy might come from an individual
straight white guy who thinks he's a guy
but nobody's problems comes from that
class of people it just does not happen
they're fed that lie they are brought
along blindly I hope that that Ann
Coulter clip goes viral because maybe
for a for at least some group of people
they'll be able to listen to what that
really means and reconsider and say huh
maybe if I'm if my main concern is
advocating a traditional Christian
morality maybe I won't ally with people
who want to redefine the definition of
marriage if my main concern is the State
of Israel maybe I want to lie with
people who want to wipe Israel off the
face of the map who want a boycott
divestment sanction Israel
maybe I'm who maybe that doesn't make a
whole lot of sense and speaking of our
interests Google today the CEO of Google
sundar pichai testified before the House
Judiciary Committee and this is being
totally misunderstood ostensibly the
reason why pitch eyes is testifying is
because he there has been a major data
breach at Google Google is shutting down
its social media platform Google+ I know
however will we be able to communicate
without Google+ add me to your circles
please this is abuse 'less social media
platform that nobody uses but there was
a data breach and so ostensibly this
this hearing was about the data
collection on the part of Google what
data they have what data where it's
going who can see it who can access it
that isn't the point people don't care
about that at all
what people care about is censorship and
Google using its vast resources to tip
elections in favor of the Democratic
Party against the Republican Party
that's what they care about they care
about political bias and censorship and
they don't care about data we all assume
if you live in the modern world you
assume that you have no privacy I've got
the Alexa in my home I've got my iphone
I've probably my refrigerator is
listening to me I think we probably bug
the leftist years tumblr at this point I
don't know it's so cheap data at least
China's bugging the thing there they're
putting a little spyware in all of our
other Hardware in the United States
they've probably put it into this desk
into these note cards
we don't expect privacy this is this is
a concern that I think politicians and
commentators think people care about
they don't what they actually care about
is censorship and political bias and at
least Republican representative Jim
Jordan was able to zero in on this this
is a totally telling exchange between
the Google CEO and Jim Jordan you said
she paid for rides to the polls and they
configured their features in such a way
as to get out the Latino vote and look I
actually think that's all okay but then
there's three words at the end of each
sentence that do cause me real concern
and those three words are we push to get
out the Latino vote with our features in
key states now suddenly gets political
we supported partners like voto Latino
to pay for rides to the polls in key
states now that makes everything
different so I got really just one
question for you why why why why did
Google configure its features and pay
for rides to the polls to get out the
Latino vote only in key states
congressman Issa said earlier we found
no evidence to substantiate those claims
listen what a remarkable answer so as
Jim Jordan lays out we have the woman
who's the head of multicultural
marketing admit that she did this admit
that she used Google's vast resources
some of the most plentiful resources in
the entire history of the world to get
out the vote of a demographic that votes
overwhelmingly for Democrats in key
states what makes them key States
Democrats have to win them they could be
swing states they're trying to push it
for Democrats you've got the head of
multicultural marketing whatever that is
admitting this you then ever referring
to sundar pichai the CEO right they're
praising her efforts and he's asked
about this and he can't quite deny it he
doesn't want to lie before the entire
country before the House Judiciary
Committee so what he says is well we
found no evidence we found Noah okay how
hard did you look because I found
evidence just in what Jim Jordan read
there's the evidence the head of
multicultural marketing admits it
and you bragged about it that's the
evidence we found no evidence okay I
found no evidence that that President
JFK was assassinated I have no evidence
of that I mean obviously I've seen Ted
Cruz's father so I suppose there's a
little evidence there but I have no
evidence that that happened
now I haven't looked into it I don't
know I haven't seen John Kennedy in a
long time but I've got no evidence of it
that it's it's totally obtuse he's
trying to hide what he's really behind
but it goes further than that Jim Jordan
to his great credit presses on and and
pichai doesn't get any better he's just
as opaque and untransparent as his
company is toward its political
practices you're a head of multicultural
marketing who you praised her work in
this email gave her a shout out was
lying when she said you were trying to
get out the Latino vote in key states we
today in the u.s. our own elections we
make it and this is what users look to
us for where to register to or where to
find your nearest polling place what are
the hours they are open and we do not
what a little things effectively I
appreciate that mr. pyncheon RT I
already said that's just that's being a
good good corporate citizen what I'm
asking is why did you only do it in key
states we didn't do any such activity as
Google on any of these key states we
didn't do any such activity as Google
well what's the parent company of Google
is called alphabet did you do it as
alphabet you didn't do it as Google did
you do it as the Google office of
multicultural marketing you didn't do it
as did you do it as YouTube did you do
Google is one of the biggest companies
in the history of the world I don't who
cares how they did it you've got the
head of this major department and the
CEO of the freaking company saying that
it happened and now you are looking me
in the eye and telling me that it didn't
happen that there's no evidence of it
that you're not sure give me a break I
love that Jordan presses on and he keeps
the way that you know that Pitchai is is
guilty as sin here is that he answers a
different question says why'd you get at
the vote in key states he said well we
love busing people to the polls to do
our civic duty and to Jason right yeah I
didn't ask
I said why'd you do it in key states and
he gives another answer he tries to
divert this is what people care about
this is what people care about they care
about the political bias because if
Google is getting out the vote in key
states fill in the blank key states for
Democrats then Google is making an
in-kind contribution to Democrats a
massive in-kind contribution to
Democrats this certainly would be in
violation of election laws and we just
saw the president's longtime personal
lawyer sent to the clink for three years
they're gonna try to use this to impeach
Donald Trump on the basis of a very
minor campaign contribution hundred
thirty thousand dollars very minor
compared to what kind of money Google is
laying out very minor compared to the
money that Barack Obama was caught
illegally contributing to his campaign
two million dollars in that case 1.8
million but they're throwing Trump's
lawyer to the clink this is a very
important point this is what people care
about and they care about the the bias
when it relates to them personally am I
gonna be kicked off YouTube like Gavin
McGinnis was why was Kevin McGinnis
kicked off YouTube he's a he's a funny
conservative comedian did you tell a
joke oh heaven forfend they kick him
that's what we care about because if
Google comes out and says we're gonna
kick all conservatives off our platform
okay I guess at least you're being
transparent at least we can all see you
for what you are which is partisan hacks
we'll go try to find another place that
won't kick us off because they're so
upset that a Republican won an election
but they won't do that so we've got to
just keep pressing hard on this we've
got to keep focusing and not lose sight
of and get mixed in the into Google's
civic responsibility into Google's data
collection into debt that's not what
we're concerned about we're concerned
about what it means for politics and we
will get into Michael Cohen's sentencing
because it does say a lot about where
this special counsel investigation is
going to be going especially once
Democrats take the house with regard to
Donald Trump will Trump be impeached
will we have a government shutdown
before Nancy Pelosi takes over and why
our millennial men is so embarrassing we
will we will examine the new baby it's
cold outside but first if you are on
daily wired
thank you very much you keep the lights
on you keep khofifah in my cup if you
are not go over there it's nothing
come on the Trump economy has been great
you got you saving a lot of money on
your taxes ten bucks a month $100 for an
annual membership you get me you get the
end replacement show you get the Ben
Shapiro show it test questions in the
mailbag that's coming up on Thursday so
get your questions in you could test
questions in the conversation you can't
ask questions in backstage you get
another Kingdom you get everything I
can't believe we do all of this we're
the hardest-working people in show
business go to daily wire comm because
none of that matters what really matters
is the leftist ears tumblr and you're
gonna need it this holiday season
because snow is thicker then than just
rain water so when the weather gets cold
outside those leftist tears are gonna
poof up and you could drown in an
avalanche of them don't be caught use
the only fda-approved vessel to carry
them
the leftist tears tumblr we'll be right
back
so cohen goes to the clink for three
years longtime lawyer to donald trump
nancy pelosi
is threatening all of these
investigations once she takes over
control of the House of Representatives
which is going to be happening in just a
month it's really close it's right
around the corner the question is when
are we going to get the wall
Donald Trump won the Republican
presidential primary on the promise of
building the wall he won the general
election on the promise of building the
wall he had the government for two years
the United government where is the wall
where is the money for the wall and
Coulter we talked about her earlier she
said there the wall is not being built
if anyone thinks the wall is being built
they're suckers where is the wall this
is the showdown fight and we'll know
next Friday if the government is going
to be shut down to get funding for the
border wall I think the President Trump
is bluffing
Senator John Kennedy Republican thinks
that he is not bluffing here's Kennedy
on CNN well let me put it another way I
think we're gonna have a shutdown you do
and I think what I do and I think we're
going to have a shutdown for two reasons
number one a president Trump does not
look to me like he was bluffing or is
bluffing and number two I don't think
speaker Pelosi is going to agree to
anything because she's worried about our
speakership and are you comfortable if
there's a shutdown next Friday because
over this border wall funding no
absolutely not
I mean I think the the American people
look to us up here to try to make things
work and who gets blamed if there's a
shutdown do you think that if as far as
I'm concerned if it's shut down it's a
pox on all of our houses I don't know
politically who's gonna win or lose this
who gets blamed who gets the credit
I'd love to can I take credit for it can
I take responsibility shut it down I
would love to be the guy who shut down
the government over the border wall
president Trump yesterday in that
back-and-forth chess match with Chuck
Schumer he finally arrived at that
position which is the correct position
own it take responsibility it doesn't
matter the conventional wisdom is that
people get blamed and that's going to
hurt them at the elections if they shut
down the government
no way shut it down shut it down would
you remember oh no do you remember when
Republicans got blown out in the 2014
elections because they shut the
government down in 2013 oh no I don't
either they took the Senate in 2014
doesn't matter at all people don't it
doesn't matter for a few reasons one
we're very angry that we don't have the
wall we're very angry that 3,000 people
a day are pouring over our border
illegally unvetted people people that we
we can't track we don't know many of
them are criminals and this is true not
just of among conservatives but it's
true among independents and left wingers
too even among Democrats we don't like
illegal immigration this is a totally
winning issue and John Kennedy says that
he's not bluffing and that we're gonna
shut the government down I think he's
bluffing I think President Trump is
bluffing I'm sorry to say he threatened
to shut the government down over this
exact issue in February what happened
didn't happen he threatened to shut down
the government over this exact issue in
July what happened didn't happen I think
he's bluffing
and I think he sent John Kennedy on TV
to say he's super serious this time
about shutting it down and I think he's
not going to shut it down I hope he does
shut it down I hope someone in the White
House is watching this show and this is
the last chance and boaters look voters
have short memories they give you a lot
of leeway this administration has been
terrific on so many issues but now when
it matters most you you're you're
looking at a House of Representatives
controlled by Democrats in just one
month and we're probably not gonna get
that house back and we're not gonna be
able to push through legislation and
what is President from focusing on now
criminal justice reform is focusing on
the first-step Act he's focusing on what
letting prisoners out of prison instead
of building the wall do you think does
anybody think Donald Trump won the
election in 2016 because he said I'm
gonna let prisoners out of prison early
does anybody does he think that
Republicans want criminal justice reform
which is to be read as letting people
out of the clink no of course not we
don't want that why on earth he's the
the gamble that the White House is
making on criminal justice reform
quote-unquote is that it's easy to get
through because Democrats want it people
don't realize that the criminal justice
exists to punish criminals for crime it
is punitive it is retributive it is not
primarily therapeutic it's not primarily
about rehabilitating people and making
people hug each other and having a nice
time it is primarily about punishing
people for crime and they're also
betting that people are going to think
that we've got zillions of people in
America in jail for non-violent minor
drug offenses when in reality the people
even who are listed for that very often
have just pled it down from selling
drugs from dealing drugs from getting
people hooked on poison and from
carrying guns from violent crimes from
bad associations they're focusing on
that the White House wants to pass the
first step backed criminal justice
reform and they're gonna let this wall
issue just go away and it is a huge huge
mistake they will get no credit for it
in the elections and it's it's just bad
for the country you have the record high
illegal immigration pouring over the
border build the wall shut it down you
won't get blamed politically if you shut
it down and you'll get a huge reward
either if you do get the funding and
you're able to build it or you call
attention to this issue and Democrats
get dinged for it because they want open
borders and they want to abolish law
enforcement shut it down if that means
tabeling criminal justice reform all the
better good I hope I hope they do that
but shut this is the last chance this is
do or die
I hope John Kennedy is right I hope
President Trump isn't bluffing if
President Trump if you think that you
are bluffing don't Bluff do it
you will be rewarded for it it will be a
good thing for the country we've got to
get to these judicial rulings by the way
I mean this is this is big news
president Trump's longtime lawyer
Michael Cohen is being sent to prison
for three years for a campaign finance
violation which means they are using
this as the warning shot to go after
President Trump all the more reason to
shut down the government and build the
wall the walls the proverbial walls are
closing in around the president right
now all of the forces who were very
upset about the 2016 election and want
to undo it by anti-constitutional
anti-democratic means of endless
investigations and trying to get him on
trumped-up charges pun very much
intended they are closing in on him so
what's the ruling we know that that
Michael Cohen is getting three years
he's the first
of the Trump inner circle to be
sentenced in jailed over a special
council office inquiry he was he was
behaving like a woman I mean I don't
mean woman like womanly like like you
know when women women behave as women I
mean when men behave as one women woman
ish sort of inappropriate to his
position inappropriate to what how he
should behave in
he he was crying apparently in court he
said that his weakness was his loyalty
to Donald Trump
he felt his duty to cover up Donald
Trump's dirty deeds he's giving the
office of the Special Counsel whatever
they want he was singing their tunes now
and he now knows he has no chance of
getting a presidential pardon
so he's weeping in court no gosh why did
I ever do it this is the man who on the
other sexually to use another gendered
term on this he had this ridiculous
machismo this fake manliness two years
ago when he said I would take a bullet
for Trump I'm not a rat I would never
sing on Trump and then what does he do
he cries in court as he gives away
everything and blames Trump for all of
his own problems so he's going to jail
for three years he'll probably get out
early though he's going to jail over a
$130,000 campaign contribution maybe
campaign contribution might have not
even been an in-kind campaign
contribution because because President
Trump regularly paid off women Barack
Obama's campaign in 2008 had one point
eight million dollars in illegal
donations opaque untransparent fake
signatures fake donors who went to jail
for that who went to jail for three
years for that nobody nobody did
$300,000
fine was put put on them for two million
dollars in illegal contributions how
about when Dinesh D'Souza donated 30
grand to his friend Wendy long he
donated a little bit too much money to
his friend Wendy long went to a halfway
house room in the clink this is what
this is what this ruling means they're
gonna try to go after Trump but
ironically they probably can't really
get him on this one it's gonna be really
really hard to say that he made any
illegal campaign contribution he's the
candidate he can donate donate what he
wants to if he didn't disk
it's gonna be really hard to get him
even ex Senator John Edwards got off on
this in 2012 it's gonna be really hard
to get the sitting president also they
can't get him on this until he's out of
office so and if he wins re-election it
actually has passed the time of the
statute of limitations for this so it's
gonna be a very interesting legal
question to see what happens to him if
he wins re-election how they can go
after him it's just a way to scare Trump
it's just a way to politically damage
him I don't think that any of these
sentences mean that they're going to
legally damage him I think they're going
to politically damage him try to ruin
his chances at re-election which is what
this whole Russia investigation was
really about why on earth is the special
counsel of the Russia investigation why
is he sending going to jail for campaign
finance is that what does that have to
do with Russian interference in the
election nothing is what it has to do
with him but there was a great ruling
that came out today as well stormy
Daniels owes Donald Trump 300 grand and
she owes it to him for a lawsuit that
Michael avenatti her her creepy porn
lawyer is Tucker Carlson calls him
apparently filed without her consent at
all
so she now isn't 300 grand it's 75% of
trumps illegal bill in this to use the
terms of the judge meritless defamation
lawsuit against donald trump avenatti
still insists that they will win one and
a half million dollars from donald trump
on a case regarding that nondisclosure
agreement that stormy Daniels signed
likely they will not it's a very shaky
case so really tough day for Mike 11
know how to in stormy Daniels but good
make them pay up it's outrageous that
people get off the hook for these
frivolous lawsuits for these frivolous
claims against Republican figures and
conservative figures so take him to the
cleaners and I hope I have a noddy's got
to pay it to the popular take here is
that you know wouldn't it be better if
we didn't have all these lawsuits
swirling around wouldn't it be better if
we had an unimpeachable candidate you
know I'm mike pence or somebody in
office instead of donald trump and we
wouldn't have to deal with all of these
lawsuit threats legal threats and
wouldn't it be better come on admit it
would be better no it wouldn't be better
it would not be better Democrats and the
Left would treat any candidate exactly
the way that they're treating Donald
Trump they did it to Brett Kavanaugh
Brett Kavanaugh is
milquetoast as they get they tried to
paint him to be a gang rapist federal
judge for a dozen years no ever no one
has ever suggested he's got a poor
character they did it to him they did it
to Mitt Romney they said Mitt Romney was
a gay bashing dog abuser Mitt Romney is
like the squeakiest clean squeaky
cleanest guy in America it wouldn't
matter it wouldn't matter it's a it's a
huge mistake for conservatives to say
well Trump brought it on himself yeah
maybe he did but they'd go after a guy
who didn't bring it on himself - it's
exactly the same those are the judicial
rulings before we go we got to talk
about baby it's cold outside there's a
new baby it's cold outside this is from
songwriters Liddy Eliza and Josiah
lemansky and they quote revised the
lyrics to emphasize the importance of
consent in sexual relationships when I
heard this I thought it was a parody I
thought it was pretty funny was it was a
parody of PC feminist culture come to
find out it's not they really did it to
make the song more culturally acceptable
if you haven't heard it here it is I
really can't stay being fine with that
I've got to go away baby I'm cool with
that this evening has been open you get
a sofa
I'm glad you
good time will start to calm and so she
knows that your father will be pacing in
flat again you're gone so really I'd
better scurry and pick it up should I
use the front or back door which one are
you pullin to his neighbors might think
you're a real nice girl say what is this
dream I wish I knew how to break the
spell
to say no no no right to say no least
I'm gonna say that reserve the right to
say you reserve the right to say no not
exactly Giacomo Casanova over there
talking about pomegranate Lacroix and
how she should text her mother and just
go the argument that the left is making
is that the first song is about rape
it's obviously not about rape the woman
wants to stay just as much as the man
she says many times that she she can
have another half a drink oh she can
have another cigarette more she is
looking for excuses to get around the
social mores that say that she should
have modesty and virtue and not stick
around with the guy and canoodle on the
first date but they both want to
canoodle just as much this has been
twisted by the left and so the answer
right now is this awful clinical song
the it's this awful clinical
relationship between men and women where
the man doesn't pursue the woman it is
now considered a rape culture for a man
to pursue a woman it should just it
should only there should never be any
pursuin see if you try to kiss a woman
that can be called sexual assault under
certain broad definitions of this is any
man as any woman rather attracted to
that guy of course not
not a single I don't care how feminist
you pretend to be
how left-wing how I'm with her or
whatever nobody is attracted to that guy
that guy is profoundly repulsive it's
not because being effeminate is
repulsive just like earlier i said the
michael cohen cried like a woman the
only reason that that is an insult is
because michael cohen isn't a woman he's
a man he's supposed to be a man he's
supposed to behave like a man but that
guy won't behave like a man compare that
version to the betty corridor ray
charles version of that song and listen
just listen if you hear any difference
at all i really can't
better it's cold outside I've got to
come wait it's cool now this evening has
me and hoping if you
[Music]
they're just like to beauty
[Music]
why don't you put some records oh oh
listen that fireplace roar so it's
getting so hot in here I can't that is a
song that is seductive and it's you hear
it in both of their voices it's this
game
the woman is teasing the man's that I
really should go what are you gonna do
what's that gonna make you say oh you
should stay no well I don't know I
really should go now don't you think
this is a beautiful thing this is a
beautiful dance the image that you have
when you listen to this is the dance of
men and women in a game of seduction and
teasing and romance what you hear in the
first left-wing version are too
apathetic bored depressed Millennials
who are so socially awkward they have no
idea how men and women are supposed to
interact with each other if if the woman
did stick around cuz it's cold outside
the guy would have no idea what to do
he's rushing her at the door cuz he has
no idea what to do he has no idea what
romance is which world do you want to
live him do you want to live in the
world of pomegranate Lacroix and sad
Millennials or do you want to live in
the world of Betty Carter and Ray
Charles well I know what I want I want
that fireplace to roar alright that's
our show I ran late today
[Music]
the Michael Nolt show is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is Austin Stevens edited by Jim nickel
audio is mixed by mic core Amina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knowles show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you